- Welcome to another coffee break
on my channel "Firm Learning."
Today, I'm back in my flat in Munich.
We got a new balcony
and I spent some time building
the new furniture today
but now I'm back and creating
today's video for you.
And today I'm talking about
a topic that already talked
about several times on this channel
and this is slide writing.
I want to help you to create
presentations in the style
of leading consulting firms
like McKinsey, BCG, Bain.
And in today's video, we combine learnings
from different other videos
that I already created
on this channel.
If you've never seen any of these videos
I will link a playlist
somewhere above here
because today I'm talking
about the creation of charts.
So whenever you will work with data
in your job, in industry or in consulting,
charts would always be
a major part of this.
I will show you how to
put together a chart
that it looks professional,
that it speaks for itself.
So stay tuned and let's dive in.
For the purpose of this video,
I selected a bit more of a complex chart
and what you can see here
is different countries.
So you can see them as for instance
business units of a company and
all their three data points.
Each of these countries
has three data points
that are depicted here in this chart.
And ed, the example of Germany,
you see that this geography
for this specific company has
a certain operating margin.
Here's something slightly below eight.
It has a CAGR, a compounded
annual growth rate
of the business of around 6%.
So how much is this business
growing year on year?
And then there is the market size,
the market size that is here
now reflected in the diameter
in the size of this circuit
that is displayed here.
And for charts like this,
for your three dimensions that
you wanna show such a chart
with an X and a Y axis,
and then also the size of
the bubbles, for instance
as third dimension often works quite well.
Now, in this video, I
wanna put your attention
to different aspects of
this different things
that you can now do to
make this chart look like
it would have been
created by a professional
consulting firm like
McKinsey, BCG, or Bain.
Now, for starters
I'd like to put your
attention on the layout.
So this is a rather clean layout.
Now you could easily make
this layout much more messy.
You could, for instance
include different colors for the circuits
include the separator lines
make this blue, for instance, this red.
So now I introduce different colors
for the different circuits.
And this is what I often see people do,
color it all up, make it look colorful,
but this is not what you wanna do.
The basic rule is that
whenever you use color,
color should always have a meaning.
And if it doesn't really portray a message
you rather go for a basic unified color
without any differentiation in
the colors that you're using.
So if you use color, make
sure to portray meaning by it.
So what could be meaning that
will justify the use of color?
So if, you know, look at this chart
one conclusion that you
might be able to draw
from this chart is that
there're actually two regions
which are extremely interesting
and relevant for this company.
And this would likely be Asia
Pacific and North America.
Because the business in Asia
Pacific has a high margin,
it is growing extremely
fast and it is rather large.
And regarding North America,
the numbers are slightly
larger than Asia Pacific,
but the business is even larger,
making it relevant as well.
Now, if you would want to emphasize this,
this is the message of this chart.
You could now go ahead and for instance
color these two regions
in blue, just to show
that this is where the focus
of the audience should be at.
Next thing to look out for are
the legends, the axis labels.
And you see that now we
have really three legends
or three types of
dimensions we need to label.
First, the x-axis, the CAGR,
then Y axis is operating margin.
And then there's additional
information on the diameter.
So again, CAGR stands for
compounded annual growth rate.
Pretty much shows how much this company
or this business unit, this
region is growing year on year.
And if you want to see
more from me on this topic
because this video is indeed
combining different elements
of other videos I already created,
check out my playlist on slide writing.
I will insert a link to the
playlist somewhere above here,
and I even have a full online
course on slide writing.
There will be a link to that included
in the video description.
This is a multi-hour program
where I teach you all the relevant skills
and tactics that you need to
create slide presentations
in the style of leading consulting firms.
So if this is of interest to you,
have a look at the link
in the video description.
But now if you've seen my other videos,
you know that one of the things
that you should always look out for is
that whenever you write percentage,
so pretty much saying
that this X axis is
showing percentage figures,
you should always say the
percentage of what is shown here
because of course now
the growth rate could be
the growth rate off all
kinds of different things.
But now, here in this example,
this is supposed to be the
growth rate of the revenue.
So, let's write percentage of revenue,
just to make a clear here.
And similar is true for
the operating margin.
And now you might infer that
this refers to the revenue
but again, there are also
other margin definitions.
There also things like cost margins.
So here, it's always helpful to, again,
include percentage of
revenue, just to label margin
of what we are currently looking at.
Now to the diameter of the third dimension
with the market size.
Here, you see my suggestion
on how to call this.
Next is something that should be included
on every chart, and this is a chart title.
So I'm just cropping it
over here, a basic element.
This is pretty much just the
combination of a text box
and line element that is
just put together here.
Indeed, the chart here
should clearly label what you're seeing
because this is often quite a struggle.
You look at a chart like that,
and you're asking yourself,
what exactly am I seeing here?
So to help your reader
to make this very sane
and transparent, include a
title and clearly label that.
And for instance,
here we could write
something like key metrics
for geographical business
units, something like this.
Here again, if you have
another suggestion,
feel free to let me know in the comments.
And indeed, when you write such a title,
you can also include other
qualifiers next to it.
So for instance, here it might be relevant
from what report this is coming,
based on financial reporting, 2014,
something like that is
what you could include
just to make this a really salient.
And then potentially here you could
also include the year figure.
All right, next.
Usually when you create such a chart,
you do not want to only
leave the viewer alone
with such a shot, but
you also wanna provide
some commentary, some implications.
The famous, "So what?"
You want your chart to have a message.
And of course, if the
reader just looks at this,
it is really difficult on the first sight,
get this message out of it.
And now the question is,
how do we include this?
How do we nicely layout this?
And again, if you have
watched other videos
for me on this topic, you
know, one basic principle
of slide writing is
every slide is a table.
Every slide is a table because
it has columns and rows.
So if you look at this page
and you wanna include
additional information,
think about it as having two columns.
You have now the first
big column to the left,
where you then include
the chart as we did here.
And then you can include
a second column here
to the right and I'm
cropping over this element.
And this is now the second column,
where you can now include
some implications.
So let's just call it exactly like this.
Let's maybe make this
a little bit smaller,
give a little bit small space to this one.
So now let's copy in a text field.
And now indeed, this is
something that we can use just
to include some commentary
and some remarks.
Now, for instance,
we could write something like Asia Pacific
and North America, and
then a nice little tweak
that you can do to emphasize your message
as to bold the most important
points in every bullet.
Then it's also nice to color
it, not necessarily in black,
but maybe the main color theme
of a presentation to make
them really stick out.
This often helps to more
easily read these bullets
and get the most important points out.
Let's now finalize this
by creating another key
element of this page.
And this is of course, the action title.
Here again, I created an
extensive video on action titles.
It's in the past on my channel.
I will link it above here, check it out.
So I will not go into too much detail
on what the action title is all about
and what should be included here.
But for instance, we could write something
like company should further focus
on Asia Pacific and North America
addressing total market
of 428 Euro million.
And again, just to remind you,
it is usually a good idea
whenever you have a page with data on it,
and of course this would be frequently
the case to then also include
a number in the action title.
This makes it much more
crisp and tangible.
And this is the feeling
that you wanna go for.
I hope this was helpful.
If you have any more questions
feel free to write me a
comment in the comment section.
As you know, I will try my very best
to answer every single
comment that you write.
If you want to learn more on this topic,
I did create this full online course,
check out the link to it
in the video description.
And if you want to continue
your learning journey
on this channel, I will link a video
above here with additional
slide writing content.
So if you took any value
out of this video at all,
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also subscribe to my channel,
to stay up to date on all the content.
I'm releasing new videos
every single week.
Feel also free to follow
me on my Instagram
my handle is firmlearning.
And now I also wanna say
thanks to all the members
of the channel, you're really
making a great contribution
to the world, to the
cause of this channel.
Thank you so much.
Good weekend to all of
you and see you soon
next Saturday.